this thing is smell another world
my world of skill things from other
worlds before
she with you Cheers
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Wonder Woman video for the
ending the big twist and how it connects
to the other DC films so just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
there's a giveaway going on right now
for IMAX gift certificates all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video so let start
with the Justice League connections
first so the beginning of this movie
picks up just a couple months after the
end of Batman V Superman Batman has
found the original version of this photo
it was on Lex's hard drive this shows
her with her friends from World War 1 in
that town right after they saved it like
right after the no man's land sequence
one of my favorite parts of the movie
like after that you see her walk off she
didn't get a copy of the photo there was
that whole subplot about her trying to
get the hard drive so that she could get
the photo off of it so that Lex wouldn't
find out who she really was I wouldn't
be surprised if when Batman finally
cracks it then gives it to her that's
the first time she's seeing it so now
that it's out of the hands of Lex she's
really just relieved that Batman found
the original version the note reads
there must be an amazing story behind
this photo maybe someday you'll tell it
to me the funny thing about that is that
that date isn't that far off because the
end of the movie picks up just a little
bit after the beginning like literally
she walks up to the top of the loop and
then flies off literally flies off so
we'll talk about her powers in a second
too but you have to imagine that that
moment is happening just a little bit
before she walks into Bruce's garage as
he's working on the flying fox like
where are the others Bruce and then they
go recruit the Justice League so the end
of Batman V Superman to the beginning
and ends of Wonder Woman those sort of
bookends to the beginning of Justice
League only a couple months have gone by
so just assume for now that the DC
movies are moving forward in real time
so Superman will have been in the ground
for about a year and a half but the
other big Justice League connection is
Hippolytus story about their origins how
they came to be there was war man fought
each other
Zeus created us to bring peace then she
tells the big story of how they were
enslaved how she fought for their
liberation then they went to samus Kira
you notice in the Justice League trailer
there's a big action set piece where
they're fighting the forces of
apocalypse you spy
a ton of Amazon's flying around so
they're a little buzzy about
exact dates and when this was happening
but this is part of those ancient wars
that Hippolyta talked about now in the
Wonder Woman movie is a slightly simpler
more animated version but it was a big
bite with Darkseid forces they banished
him from the earth but the mother boxes
were left behind the Amazons have won
they did not address it during the
Wonder Woman movie at least I didn't
spot it at the screening that I went to
so let me know if you spotted a mother
box in that big silo where they kept all
their god-given weapons but speaking of
weapons the god killer sword is a total
red herring as Ares explains to her you
are the god Killer the child the Zeus
had with Hippolyta so they lied to her
about being a lump of clay which is sort
of a play on her origin story from the
comics when Hippolyta is telling young
Wonder Woman I prayed to the god Zeus to
give life to a lump of clay that's sort
of the original version of her origin
story the new 52 version is the one
where she's the legit daughter of Zeus
and Hippolyta so if there was any
confusion about that they are saying
that Wonder Woman in the DC EU is a
legit God it takes a God to kill a god
and you see how she unlocks her
abilities as she learns to believe in
herself Erie starts putting the
full-court press on her and she starts
hooking out she holds a tank over her
head for an extended period of time with
no visible exertion she flies and then
she absorbs all that energy the god
energy the Ares is calling down that
lightning is a little bit different from
regular lightning and then fires it back
at him killing him so if it's possible
to kill a God and it seems like it is
because Ares says that it takes a God to
kill a god but they're very ambiguous
about what happens to gods after they
die do they just become pure energy is
it like the comics with the new gods in
the forces of apocalypse when their
power just kind of gets sucked in to
someone else when they die so that's all
still open to wide speculation but
Wonder Woman has that comment during
Batman V Superman where she says I've
killed things that aren't from this
earth she's talking about Ares because
she killed him during the Wonder Woman
movie she also flies at the end of the
movie in sort of a mirror for the scene
where she's taking down the church
trying to get that sniper now they
freeze frame on it so he
like wait a minute what's happening here
but she is legit flying in this moment
so there was any question she probably
can't fly quite as good as Superman but
still very very good but like you see
Ares floating down from the sky in their
fight he can teleport around it will
she's probably almost as powerful as
that because Hippolyta is obviously an
Amazon more powerful than a normal human
but that makes Wonder Woman more of a
demigod
so she has most of the powers that gods
do but not quite the full extent of it
she couldn't just teleport herself
across the earth and Harry shows himself
appearing as a spirit whispering in the
ears of all the villains telling them
about formulas about how to build
weapons she's not going to be doing that
anytime soon but it seems like she has
every single ability that she does in
the comics now there been a couple
different ways they've expressed her
powers but just assume the most powerful
version of Wonder Woman in the comics is
how powerful she is in this movie so I
think I said it in my review video a
couple days ago but it makes it seem
like she really held back in her fight
against doomsday if she can Hulk out
that crazy against Aries during a lot of
the villain monologuing Ares talks about
his history on the earth after he was
struck down by Zeus in their final
battle he sort of lost the ability to
influence the entire planet
simultaneously so like a God has power
over the entire earth post Ares seemed
like he had most of his abilities in a
more localized fashion so he could
influence people but he'd have to be
standing right next to them so hopefully
that explains a little bit about his
power levels still very strong but when
he was at full power he could influence
things at a much more cosmic scale so
they basically just took the cosmic part
out of the equation she's told by
Hippolyta that when she leaves Paradise
Island that she can never come back but
I wouldn't be surprised if we see the
Amazons pop back up again in one of the
future Justice League films like they'll
come out of hiding to help and then
they'll eventually go back so I don't
think it's permanent that Wonder Woman
never goes back to temas Kiera but the
whole idea of the end of the movie her
big speech is about how she's going to
protect the earth because she believes
in love so it's not so much that she
can't go back is that she doesn't want
to go back because her mission isn't
done I've seen a couple comments on my
review video about the final fate of
Steve Trevor as well as two other
friends I think the idea is that most
have died by old age now Steve Trevor
died when he blew up the plane full of
the gas so the photos the watch is sort
of like that movie's version of the
Peggy Carter scenes when Captain America
is in present day like she's the link to
Captain America's past the only person
who remembers him from that time so
that's kind of the same vibe you get
when she stares at the watch when she
looks at the picture it reminds her of
those people that she loved of that time
in why she believes in making the world
a better place and believes in love so
much so I'm not expecting to see any of
those old characters pop back up but
patty Jenkins the director in gal gadot
have both been confirmed for a sequel if
they decide to do it
there hasn't been any official word on
when they're going to greenlight that
but I think it's a pretty done deal so
in the next couple of months you'll
probably hear more about that but they
could set it during World War Two which
is a little bit after World War one or
they could do some other time in the
past but there's still a lot of
questions about what time period it
would take place during it's just that
people love the World War one setting so
much and I think that works so well for
her character that Warner Brothers is
really open to the idea of doing another
movie set in the past so let me know
what you guys thought about Wonder Woman
I'll do an Easter Egg video next that'll
post sometime in the next couple of days
but there's some new Rick and Morty to
post there's some new spider-man Home
Coming so I'll try to get that stuff out
as fast as possible congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Rhett bo-zone
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything you can click here for my
Wonder Woman review and you can click
here for brand new flash season 4 thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you